continúa el bloqueo en la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos este
miércoles la división entre los
republicanos volvió a tumbar las
aspiraciones de Kevin mccarthy líder de
la mayoría de hacerse con la presidencia
de la cámara baja en nuevas rondas de
votación 20 republicanos de extrema
derecha le dieron nuevamente la espalda
quedándose corto de los 218 votos
necesarios
todo esto empieza teniendo un líder que
apoya los valores republicanos y genere
consensos
incluso con mi presidente favorito
llamándonos para decirnos que tenemos
que acabar con esto creo que eso se debe
revertir el presidente necesita decirle
a Kevin mccarthy no tiene los votos es
hora de retirarse
Y es que la cámara baja no puede
legislar sin presidente y si el partido
conservador no consigue llegar a un
acuerdo las reglas estipulan que las
votaciones deben continuar hasta que se
designe un líder el expresidente Donald
Trump adoptó un tono conciliador y pidió
a su partido Unión en torno a la figura
de macarthy
voten a favor de Kevin cierren el
acuerdo tomen la victoria y miren a la
loca de Nancy pelosi volver a una
California muy quebrada republicanos no
convierta en un gran triunfo en una
gigantesca y vergonzosa derrota es hora
de celebrar se lo merecen que vil
mccarthy hará un buen trabajo e incluso
un gran trabajo solo obsérvenlo el
presidente Joe biden aseguró que su
disputa da una mala imagen país creo que
es un poco vergonzoso que se esté
tardando tanto y la forma en la que lo
están haciendo entre ellos y el resto
del mundo está mirando mirando si
podemos ponernos de acuerdo tras unas
decepcionantes elecciones de medio
término en las que la María roja que
auguraba en las encuestas no se
materializó la crisis no beneficia la
imagen republicana
[Aplausos]